reyes bonjour merci d'être avec nous
bonjour monsieur ryan dites-moi réunion
de votre caucus mercredi 7 heures c'est
long c'est êtes-vous content de la
rencontre est très content puis c'est
dur et ça passe parce qu'on avait besoin
de ce secteur là pour se parler se dire
les vraies choses
après la dernière campagne que lieu mais
je pense que c'est le début d'une
introspection qui est en train de se
faire à l'intérêt de notre organisme
vous il est vrai show oui je dirais que
les bronzés pu s'exprimer
je dirais pour assister de façon très
respectueuse mais les gens qui avaient
le goût de s'exprimer ont eu
l'opportunité de le faire puis auront
d'autres opportunités avec la nomination
qui était fait de john baird qui
maintenant responsable de consulter tout
le monde dans tandis que les gens ont à
dire en vue de pouvoir prendre les
meilleures décisions en vue de la
prochaine élection elle voulait pression
d'avoir été compris je souhaite
sincèrement parce que ont fait cet
exercice là parce que oui on ne fait
plus de gains en termes de sièges en
termes de voix rebondi un peu partout
mais notre objectif d'être gagné
l'élection s'était formé un gouvernement
conservateur
puis j'irai au québec nous notre côté
mois comme lieutenant politique c'est de
faire des gains au québec lé donc ce
qu'on n'a pas réussi à faire donc il ya
des messages qui doivent se passer il ya
des gestes qui doivent être posées
c'est un peu ce qu'on voulait commencer
a traduit et tout le monde va ensemble
ils 121 députés passent à la première
occasion qu'on avait de se rencontrer
on en a beaucoup entendu parler de ce
qui s'est passé au québec chez les
commentateurs politiques chez les
analystes
jacques eu lieu dans politique vous avez
mené la campagne au québec où ils savent
ce qu'est ce qui s'est passé sur le
terrain
la première des choses je pense que tout
le monde concède on avait une équipe de
candidats extraordinaire le lion
travaille il je peux vous dire j'étais
sur le terrain avec eux les députés les
sénateurs ont travaillé très fort on a
vraiment une équipe extraordinaire
on avait travaillé au préalable sur
notre tournée les côtes des québécois
mme comette c'était quoi les
préoccupations des gens je pense qu'au
niveau des idées c'était là mais faut
croire que malgré le fait que bon la
question de la loi besson la
contesterait pour objet de leur rapport
d'impôt unique aux québécois plus de
poids des migrations en culture plus
d'argent n'est pas seulement je pense
que sur le fond tout était là mais notre
message faut croire qu'il n'a pas passé
comme on l'aurait souhaité une est
réellement les question d'enjeux sociaux
là on se mettra pas la tête dans le
sable
ça nous a fait mal la question de
l'avortement pendant la campagne c'était
même difficile pour plusieurs candidats
ou candidates
moi le premier donc il va falloir
trouver des réponses à sa va falloir
avoir un discours qui est autant entier
qui cohera en vue de la prochaine
élection qui pourrait arriver n'importe
quand le certains m'ont 19,2 en trois
ans quatre ans on n'a aucune idée là
partir d'aujourd'hui font ils ont juste
chiot le monsieur monsieur a parlé de
ses convictions personnelles ses
convictions personnelles là elles vont
pas nécessairement changer comment on
fait pour songer à faire campagne avec
monsieur shearer la tête du parti est
passé par dessus la question des enjeux
sociaux ouais c'est une bonne question
j'aimerais se connaître la réponse puis
je dirais que même personnellement c'est
difficile parce que bon je reconnais que
j'avais encore des croyances
personnelles puis là on est en train de
demander à quelqu'un de renoncer à ses
croyances moins que de trouver une façon
de les expliquer pour ne pas que les
gens soient inquiets
c'est un peu ça je pense que les gens
nous ont dit qu'ils ont senti que
c'était pas nécessairement authentique
comme des soeurs et sa statue est ce que
ça peut se faire
compte tenu de la campagne mais c'est
vrai que c'est un défi pour pour
monsieur scheer c'est clair il le sait
il entendu
il le même verbalisé à quelques reprises
dans des différentes en entrevue il va
falloir trouver une façon s'il veut
pouvoir se représenter face à
l'électorat dans une prochaine campagne
c'est clair il ya de quoi dire autrement
qu ils vont trouver une façon de
connecter avec les québécois puis on
parle du québec mon produit aussi
longtemps mais parce qu'il ya aussi dit
dans une entrevue tout récemment encore
qu'ils n'avaient pas l'intention d'aller
marcher par exemple dans des spas de la
fierté est là et ça aussi c'est un
élément qui a été soulevé par certains
seule l'étude je peux vous dirigez
partir moi ma premier à mon premier
défilé à montréal j'avais jamais
participé auparavant j'étais même
réfractaires au départ d'y aller parce
que je voulais pas me sentir
sincèrement instrumentalisée dans cet
exemple puis je pense que différentes
façons aussi de deux protégés de
défendre des personnes puissent y une
chose dans l'intérêt de mon parti et
j'en suis profondément convaincu malgré
tout ce que tout le monde peut penser et
beaucoup de mythes aussi beaucoup de
choses qui qui qui se propage dans
l'opinion publique
mais dans mon parti c'est clair on veut
défendre tout le monde quelle que soit
leur religion quelles que soient leurs
origines ou suffisent dimier fils
d'émigrés ramé parasites de sont
égyptiens
quelle que soit leur orientation
sexuelle pour nous les tuyaux aucun
compromis maintenant de quelle façon on
le transmet mais là je pense que le
message est clair on l'a reçu à la
population d envoyer un message à donner
aux élections soient ils ne l'ont
peut-être pas senti ce message le haut
sincère de ne pas à l'heure actuelle
fait chier c'est encore l'homme de la
situation pour se maintenant à partir
d'aujourd'hui le caucus s'est rangé en
arrière de notre chiffre est l'imam vous
envoie à prendre une décision au mois
d'avril prochain
notre chef est élu par rapport à claire
c'est non mais pour les gens peut-être
que dans notre conscience il ya une
chose qui est très clair c'est que c'est
les mêmes qui lisent le cher c'est les
membres qui lui redonne confiance dans
notre constitution après une défaite il
doit repasser le test du vote de
confiance sur 7 au mois d'avril que ça
doit se faire avec aujourd'hui je pense
que les gens qui ont des insatisfactions
ce qu'ils s'attendent à des actions
concrètes
suite à l'analyse qui vont en effet de
l'élection je pense que c'est ça je le
prends cette analyse là il n'y a pas
juste une problématique qui en a
quelques-unes
il faut être capable d identifier poser
les bons gestes par la suite à quel
moment vous êtes inquiet c'est plus
l'homme de la situation vous passez à
autre ou pincé tous que c'est au congrès
qui vont être activement avoir lieu au
mois d'avril que les membres pourront
s'exprimer dit le meilleur tout un
processus de réflexion qui est fait par
tout le monde et moi ce que je j'ai
confiance que les gens vont prendre la
bonne décision
neuf chefs vont faire une introspection
lyonnais mais une personne de grande
confiance dans john bien pour faire
cette analyse là je pense qu'ils reconnu
par tout ce qui est aussi très respecté
par tout le mouvement conservateur et
qui ne sait pas si c'est important les
personnes sont nommés ne proviennent pas
de la campagne électorale qui ne s'est
pas immiscé dans cette campagne donc ils
vont pouvoir jeter un regard qui est
neutre il permettre aux chefs de prendre
les bonnes décisions nécessaires entre à
connecter avec le québec par contre
monsieur b ben moi en ce moment ce qui
m'intéresse c'est que les bons messages
se rendent au chef pour qu'ils prennent
les bonnes décisions pas celui qu
apprendre des choses n'est pas john
baird
c'est un dossier qui doit prendre
édition c'est le chef c'est lui qui a la
responsabilité de monter la prochaine
équipe puis moi ce que j'ai confiance
et toutes les informations tous les gens
qui ont des choses à dire bon riz dire
ça va se faire à l'intérieur de notre
caucus
puis par la suite mais les résultats
seront là les gens proposent un jugement
au delà au delà de l'avenir du chef vous
avez dit vous avez parlé de l'équipe
parce que l'équipe est ce que vous
voulez voir des gens de l'équipe change
d'ici la prochaine campagne électorale
le rapport va voir avant d'arriver à des
conclusions mais je pense qu'on peut pas
refaire la même chose qui pensent avoir
un résultat qui différent donc il ya des
gestes qui doivent être posées
il ya personne qui était l'abri de cet
exercice là on a tous notre os pétition
à faire mouche en une affaire comme le
temps politique
mes confrères consorts en ont une
affaire notre chef en une affaire
l'équipe autour du chef prône une
affaire comment on aurait pu mieux
préparer le chef parce que des choses
qu'on aurait pu en discuter mais dire
que des gens qui doivent partir ben moi
je pense que des actions qui vont se
poser on peut pas penser à retourner la
même équipe la même gagne puis refaire
la même chose pour son résultat qui est
différent gens qui étaient à la
direction de la campagne donc la
direction de la campagne la dernière
campagne peut pas être la direction de
la prochaine karpaty ce que vous voyez
des changements qui vont vouloir que ce
soit fait tant au niveau je pense de
l'entourage qui au niveau de la
stratégie qui doit être fait je répète
on peut pour refaire la même chose pas
savoir est différent et tout le monde on
voir un exercice d'introspection à faire
dans ces exercices là à les rails et
merci beaucoup de plaisir